the hit
we can talk about russian russian
position right now this uh the
uh
war uh
back and forth back and forth uh that
many people died as many syrian people
died
it's uh it's horrible especially for
civilian
uh woman's children
our soldier
uh and uh russians explain they came to
change the government because the gallon
is bad i'm sorry every ukrainian support
the decision to be the part of european
family is a main priority for us and uh
putin not agreed with that
we don't want to live
in russian empire uh it's the main
reason why is russian soldiers coming
here every ukrainian support the
this war is
this war against the russians because we
are not aggressive was to anyone but if
some uh army comes to us we will be
fight
we
what we fight for our independency
for our family
for our future for our values
its main its main point
and can you give me a sense of how far
away the russians are now from from the
center of the the russians the russians
are mistaken the board of kiev and uh
we
it's not so far it's uh from here i
guess it's uh
20 kilometers maybe less
okay
and uh how prepared is kiev to deal with
uh invasion of russian troops uh
actually it's what did russians they
destroyed the economy of uh
of our country i expect right now the
huge humanitarian catastrophe in
uh in our country
huge humanitarian catastrophe because
our economy destroyed our infrastructure
is destroyed the people doesn't have a
job people doesn't have money
people doesn't have homes right now they
millions of people move from his houses
and what they do it they destroy the
country and uh one
one point the life of the millions of
the people the for our independency
already paid
thousands ukrainian with his uh huge
price his life but uh what what is the
next what is the next
russians
have just
expectation
of
rebuilt empire
we are don't want to russian empire we
want to fight for our independence is
the main message
we were just told that the head of the
russian delegation is waiting for a
ukrainian delegation to come to gorman
can you confirm this
yeah i have information
are you able to comment on this
uh i have information but i'm not
involved
to make a negotiation i
uh which negotiation it says
no i i the question which negotiations
is one priority
move or away from our country
but you can't comment on whether a
ukrainian delegation is coming to
government right now
no no okay
um
and
uh
can you are you able to comment on on
what the fighting has been like in
within kiev because for us reporting on
it it's been really hard to follow and
to know exactly what's going on
sometimes there's reports of shooting in
podil and then on the outskirts of kiev
can you give us a sense
the russians send some troops
small troops
which actually with some time
we as civilian with weapons snipers and
shootings away and uh they want to make
terror attack and uh to bring the
uh the panic to our city
uh it's a goal it's a goal we're uh
hunting here
of them and we
take this uh some people russians who
are coming to our city
okay and how uh yesterday there were
reports that the ukrainian forces were
seeking out these these russians within
kiev how successful has that operation
been
yeah i'm sorry i don't understand the
question exactly so yesterday there were
reports that um the ukrainian forces
were looking for groups of uh separate
russian forces within the city um how
successful has that operation been it's
it's it's a group
making division right yeah it's um
some successful but they hunting they
they
sit somewhere in snipers right now we
uh
make right now
uh announcement nobody allowed to go
from houses first of all we care about
the life of the people from one point
from another point
we try to hunting this this uh these
people it's much more this will be much
more easy if uh nobody in the street
okay so but you can't comment on on how
successful it was last night did were
you able to
to to find these groups uh what exactly
happened uh we uh we killed
some people i i guess six people in uh
last night okay um
how so you just said that the the
russian forces are roughly 20 kilometers
away from the center of kiev how long do
you think that you can actually hold off
the russian army
so long how we can
okay we will be fight so long
how we can
so that you're the resistance of of of
ukrainians would you be able to
i i listened about the plans in two days
the russians have to be here
it's not happens you know why because we
have will we have a good character
because we fight
for our
houses for our country we wins the home
and uh big demolition demoralization by
russian forces by russian soldiers
because they understand they they feel
in our country very uncomfortable
because
every ukrainian had russians
headed russians
and the message go back to home from our
country away
soon as possible
um
you there has been a decision to hand
out weapons to ukrainians who want to
defend the city and who want to defend
the country we've seen long lines of
young men it's civilian defense civil
and defense is many people ready to
fight for our country and to they asking
for the weapons and that's why uh many
of them people have for military
background and that's why we built right
now civilian defense and every uh every
uh citizens man or woman who proud of
the country can take their weapons and
defend our houses our families our
children but is this how controlled is
this do you know who is actually getting
these weapons is that
to be honest we don't have a hundred
percent control but uh we
because we
build this uh
uh
territorial defense in very short period
of time but it's patriotics
these people expected we make a group
and study them immediately and what
happens if these weapons get into the
wrong hands let's say criminals or or
people who are maybe against this you
know what right now the question much
more important to defend our country